ยินดีต้อนรับกลับมาสู่ทำความเข้าใจข้อมูลควอนตัมและการคำนวณ ผมชื่อ John watus และผมเป็นผู้อำนวยการ
ด้านเทคนิคฝ่ายการศึกษาที่ IBM Quantum นี่เป็นบทเรียนที่แปดของซีรีส์ และเป็นบทเรียนสุดท้ายใน
หน่วยที่สองของซีรีส์ ซึ่งเกี่ยวกับอัลกอริทึมควอนตัม เราได้พูดถึงโมเดลการค้นหาของการคำนวณ รวมถึงอัลกอริทึมควอนตัม
ที่มีข้อได้เปรียบที่พิสูจน์ได้เหนืออัลกอริทึมแบบคลาสสิกภายในโมเดลนั้น เราได้พูดคุยเกี่ยวกับแนวคิดพื้นฐานที่เชื่อมโยงกับ
อัลกอริทึมควอนตัมและวิธีที่เราสามารถวัดต้นทุนการคำนวณ และในบทเรียนที่แล้วเราได้พูดถึง phase estimation และอัลกอริทึมของ Shore
ในบทเรียนนี้เราจะพูดถึงอัลกอริทึมของ Grover ซึ่งให้ข้อได้เปรียบแบบกำลังสองของควอนตัมเหนือ
อัลกอริทึมแบบคลาสสิกสำหรับปัญหาการค้นหาแบบไม่มีโครงสร้าง ซึ่งผมจะอธิบายเมื่อเราเข้าสู่
บทเรียน เหล่านี้เป็นหัวข้อพื้นฐานทั้งหมดเกี่ยวกับอัลกอริทึมควอนตัม ยังมีอัลกอริทึมควอนตัม
อื่นๆ อีก รวมถึงกรอบแนวคิดทั่วไปที่รวมอัลกอริทึมควอนตัมต่างๆ และเทคนิคเชิงอัลกอริทึมควอนตัม และ
ถ้าสนใจ ผมแนะนำให้ลองดู quantum algorithm Zoo ที่จัดหมวดหมู่อัลกอริทึมควอนตัมที่รู้จัก และรวมถึงเอกสารอ้างอิงมากมาย
จากงานวิจัยต้นฉบับที่มีส่วนร่วมในการพัฒนา แต่สำหรับซีรีส์นี้
เราจะยึดกับพื้นฐานเท่านั้น และเริ่มจากบทเรียนถัดไปเราจะไปสู่หัวข้อใหม่ แต่
ก่อนอื่นมาพูดถึงอัลกอริทึมของ Grover กันก่อน นี่คือภาพรวมของบทเรียน เราจะเริ่มด้วยการพูดคุยสั้นๆ เกี่ยวกับ
ปัญหาการคำนวณที่เราจะจัดการ ซึ่งก็คือการค้นหาแบบไม่มีโครงสร้าง พูดง่ายๆ ก็คือ
ลองนึกถึงปัญหาการค้นหาแบบไม่มีโครงสร้างว่าเป็นการค้นหาผ่านกลุ่มรายการที่ไม่ได้เรียงลำดับ และไม่ได้ถูกจัดเรียงในทาง
ที่เป็นประโยชน์ จากนั้นเราจะพูดถึงอัลกอริทึมของ Grover ซึ่งเป็นอัลกอริทึมควอนตัมที่ให้ข้อได้เปรียบแบบกำลังสองเหนือ
อัลกอริทึมแบบคลาสสิก และเราจะลงรายละเอียดว่ามันหมายความว่าอย่างไร คำอธิบายคร่าวๆ ในระดับสูงของ
วิธีที่อัลกอริทึมนี้ทำงานก็คือ ก่อนอื่นมีขั้นตอนการเริ่มต้น แล้วก็มีการดำเนินการที่ผมจะเรียกว่า
การดำเนินการ Grover ถูกทำซ้ำหลายรอบ และสุดท้ายจะมีการวัดที่เปิดเผยคำตอบที่เป็นไปได้
ของปัญหาการค้นหา ผมจะอธิบายว่าการดำเนินการ Grover คืออะไร และสามารถ
นำไปใช้บนคอมพิวเตอร์ควอนตัมได้อย่างไร แล้วเราจะวิเคราะห์การดำเนินการนี้เพื่อเข้าใจได้ดีขึ้นว่ามันทำอะไรและทำไมมันถึงมีประโยชน์สำหรับ
การค้นหา ส่วนที่สามของบทเรียนเกี่ยวข้องกับจำนวนรอบการทำซ้ำ
ในอัลกอริทึมของ Grover หรือพูดอีกอย่างก็คือจำนวนครั้งที่ควรใช้การดำเนินการ Grover โดยสมมติว่าเราต้องการ
เพิ่มโอกาสที่อัลกอริทึมจะสำเร็จในการหาสิ่งที่เราค้นหา พร้อมกับลดต้นทุน
ให้น้อยที่สุด เราจะเริ่มด้วยปัญหาการค้นหาที่มีคำตอบเดียว ซึ่งเป็นกรณีพิเศษที่มีคำตอบเดียวเท่านั้นสำหรับ
ปัญหาการค้นหาของเรา แล้วเราจะพิจารณาว่าจะเกิดอะไรขึ้นเมื่อมีคำตอบหลายคำตอบ และสุดท้ายผมจะปิดท้าย
บทเรียนด้วยข้อสังเกตสั้นๆ เกี่ยวกับอัลกอริทึมของ Grover และการขยายผลของมัน มาเริ่มกับ
ปัญหาการคำนวณที่เราจะจัดการตลอดบทเรียนกัน ก่อนอื่น อย่างที่เราทำบ่อยๆ เราจะ
ให้ Sigma แทนตัวอักษรไบนารี และเราจะใช้สัญกรณ์นี้ตลอดทั้งบทเรียน ดังนั้นผมจะไม่คอย
เตือนนะ สมมติว่าเรามีฟังก์ชัน f ที่แมปสตริงไบนารีที่มีความยาว n ไปยัง
ตัวอักษรไบนารี สมมติฐานของเราคือเราสามารถประเมินฟังก์ชันนี้ได้ง่ายๆ
ตัวอย่างเช่น อาจจะมี Boolean circuit สำหรับฟังก์ชันนี้ที่ขนาดเป็นพหุนามใน N ทีนี้ไม่ได้หมายความว่า
มันจะเป็นฟังก์ชันง่ายๆ ในแง่ใดแง่หนึ่ง หรือว่าเราเข้าใจฟังก์ชันนี้ดีเป็นพิเศษ เช่น อาจจะมี
Boolean circuit ที่ซับซ้อนและยุ่งเหยิงสำหรับการคำนวณ F ที่ช่วยให้เราประเมินมันบนสตริงอินพุตต่างๆ ได้ แต่ไม่จำเป็นต้องมี
รูปแบบที่สวยงามที่ออกแบบมาเพื่อทำให้ชีวิตเราง่ายขึ้น เป้าหมายของเราคือหาคำตอบ โดย
หมายถึงสตริงไบนารีที่มีความยาว n ที่ทำให้ F มีค่าเป็นหนึ่ง โดยทั่วไปนี่เป็นปัญหา
การคำนวณที่ยากมาก หรืออย่างน้อยเราก็สงสัยว่ามันยากมาก โดยเฉพาะอย่างยิ่งถ้าอินพุตเป็น
คำอธิบายของ Boolean circuit สำหรับการคำนวณฟังก์ชัน f แล้วนี่จะเป็นปัญหาที่เรียกว่า NP-complete วิธีหนึ่ง
ที่เราสามารถทำให้ปัญหานี้เป็นทางการได้คือเป็นปัญหาการค้นหา และจริงๆ แล้วสำหรับจุดประสงค์ของบทเรียนนี้ก็สมเหตุสมผล
ที่จะคิดเกี่ยวกับปัญหานี้ในบริบทของโมเดลการค้นหาเท่านั้น แต่เมื่อเราคิดว่าปัญหา
นี้อาจเกิดขึ้นจริงเมื่อไหร่หรือที่ไหน มันน่าจะเป็นธรรมชาติมากกว่าที่จะคิดว่า f ถูกคำนวณโดย Boolean
circuit อย่างที่เราเห็นในบทเรียนที่หก เราสามารถเชื่อมมุมมองทั้งสองนี้ผ่านการสร้างที่เราได้ทำไปสำหรับการเอา Boolean circuit มา
แปลงเป็น circuit ควอนตัมสำหรับการใช้งานการดำเนินการค้นหาหรือ gate ค้นหา ไม่ว่ายังไง ในเชิงแนวคิด
อินพุตของปัญหาคือฟังก์ชัน f นี้ และเรากำลังมองหาคำตอบถ้ามี และถ้า
ไม่มีคำตอบ หมายความว่า F กลายเป็นฟังก์ชันคงที่ศูนย์ ผลลัพธ์ที่ถูกต้องคือรายงาน
ว่าไม่มีคำตอบ นี่คือปัญหาการค้นหาแบบไม่มีโครงสร้าง ในแง่ที่ว่า
ไม่มีอะไรพิเศษเกี่ยวกับ F ที่ทำให้หาคำตอบได้ง่าย มันไม่เหมือนกับการค้นหา
ผ่านข้อมูลที่ถูกจัดเรียงแล้ว หรือถูกโหลดเข้าไปในโครงสร้างข้อมูลที่ช่วยให้ค้นหาได้ง่าย และไม่มีเงื่อนไขเกี่ยวกับ
ฟังก์ชัน f ที่อาจช่วยเราได้ วิธีหนึ่งที่จะคิดก็คือ มันเหมือนกับการค้นหาเบอร์โทรศัพท์
ในสมุดโทรศัพท์ เมื่อเทียบกับการค้นหาชื่อ ซึ่งง่ายกว่ามากโดยสมมติว่าชื่อ
ถูกเรียงตามตัวอักษรแล้ว ในทางปฏิบัติ มันไม่ได้เกี่ยวกับการค้นหาผ่านข้อมูล
ซึ่งเรามักจะจัดระเบียบและเก็บในลักษณะที่ทำให้ค้นหาง่าย มันเป็นตัวแทนมากกว่าของการค้นหา
คำตอบของสมการที่ซับซ้อน หรืออาจจะเป็นการค้นหาชุดตัวเลขที่เปิด
แม่กุญแจ เป็นข้อสังเกตเล็กๆ ว่ามันสมเหตุสมผลที่จะคิดเกี่ยวกับปัญหานี้ในบริบทของโมเดลการค้นหา ไม่ว่าเราจะรู้สึกอย่างไร
เกี่ยวกับความเกี่ยวข้องในทางปฏิบัติของโมเดลนั้น แน่นอนว่าในชีวิตจริงไม่มีออราเคิลหรือกล่องดำ แต่จนกว่าเราจะ
ค้นพบอะไรเพิ่มเติม Boolean circuit ที่ซับซ้อนและลึกลับก็เหมือนกับกล่องดำ
นั่นเอง ทีนี้มาคิดเรื่องอัลกอริทึมสำหรับแก้ปัญหาการค้นหาแบบไม่มีโครงสร้างกัน และเราจะทำ
ในโมเดลการค้นหาเพื่อความเรียบง่าย ถ้าเรามี Boolean circuit สำหรับฟังก์ชันของเราแทนที่จะเป็นกล่องดำ
เราก็ยังสามารถรันอัลกอริทึมการค้นหาบนมันได้ แต่แน่นอนว่าเราไม่สามารถตัดความเป็นไปได้ที่อัลกอริทึมใหม่
จะถูกค้นพบสำหรับปัญหานี้ที่ไม่ได้อิงกับการค้นหา แต่เราจะไม่สนใจเรื่อง
ความเป็นไปได้นั้น ก่อนอื่นแค่เรื่องสัญกรณ์เล็กน้อย จำนวนทั้งหมดของสตริงอินพุตของฟังก์ชัน f คือ 2 ยกกำลัง
n ตัวเล็ก โดยที่ n ตัวเล็กคือความยาวของสตริงอินพุตของ F และต่อจากนี้ผมจะให้ N ตัวใหญ่เป็นจำนวนนี้ 2 ยกกำลัง
n ตัวเล็ก เป็นเรื่องปกติที่คนจะใช้ตัวอักษรตัวใหญ่แบบนี้เพื่อแทน 2 ยกกำลังตัวอักษรตัวเล็ก
ของตัวอักษรนั้น เราจะพูดถึงจำนวน N ตัวใหญ่ค่อนข้างบ่อย ดังนั้นมันก็แค่จะ
สะดวก และจะช่วยให้ทุกอย่างดูเรียบร้อยขึ้น และสัญกรณ์นี้ใช้ตลอดทั้ง
บทเรียนนะ แน่นอนว่าเราสามารถแก้ปัญหาการค้นหาแบบคลาสสิกได้โดยแค่
วนผ่านสตริง n บิตที่เป็นไปได้ทั้งหมดในลำดับใดก็ได้ที่เราเลือก ประเมิน F กับแต่ละอัน
ถ้าเราหาคำตอบเจอเมื่อไหร่ก็หยุดได้ แต่ในกรณีที่แย่ที่สุดเราจะต้องประเมิน F กับทุกสตริง
อินพุต ดังนั้นจึงต้องใช้ N คือ N ตัวใหญ่
ครั้งในการค้นหา เราอาจเลือกวัดต้นทุนของการคำนวณนี้ด้วยวิธีอื่น ไม่ใช่แค่จำนวนครั้งการค้นหา แต่จำนวนครั้งการค้นหา
แทนจำนวนครั้งที่เราต้องประเมินฟังก์ชัน f และมันสมเหตุสมผลที่จะคาดว่าการประเมิน f จะเป็นต้นทุนหลัก
ของการคำนวณนี้ นี่คือสิ่งที่ดีที่สุดที่เราทำได้ด้วยอัลกอริทึมแบบกำหนดได้
และอีกครั้ง นี่อยู่ในบริบทของโมเดลการค้นหา ถ้าเราค้นหาสตริงอินพุต
ทุกตัวยกเว้นตัวเดียว และ F ให้ค่าศูนย์กับทุกตัวจนถึงตอนนี้ เราจะมั่นใจได้ยังไงว่าสตริง
ตัวสุดท้ายไม่ใช่คำตอบ และคำตอบก็คือมั่นใจไม่ได้ ดังนั้นเราต้องใช้ทั้ง N ครั้งในการค้นหาในกรณี
ที่แย่ที่สุด เราอาจใช้ความสุ่มซึ่งให้การปรับปรุงเล็กน้อย เช่น ลด
จำนวนครั้งที่คาดว่าจะต้องค้นหาเพื่อหาคำตอบเมื่อมีคำตอบอยู่ หรือเราอาจแลกความน่าจะเป็น
ของความถูกต้องกับการลดจำนวนครั้งการค้นหา แต่ไม่ว่าจะมองยังไงก็ยังต้องใช้จำนวนครั้งการค้นหาที่เป็นเชิงเส้น
ใน N ดังนั้นในเชิงคลาสสิก เราต้องใช้จำนวนครั้งการค้นหาแบบเชิงเส้น หมายถึงเชิงเส้น
ใน N ตัวใหญ่ อัลกอริทึมของ Grover เป็นอัลกอริทึมควอนตัมสำหรับการค้นหาที่ทำได้ดีกว่า มันต้องการแค่ Big O ของ
รากที่สองของ N ครั้งในการค้นหา การค้นหาเหล่านั้นเกิดขึ้นในสถานะซ้อนทับ ดังนั้นมันไม่ใช่เวทมนตร์ แต่มันก็
เป็นการปรับปรุงที่สำคัญเหนือสิ่งที่เป็นไปได้แบบคลาสสิก และนี่คือสิ่งที่หมายถึงข้อได้เปรียบแบบ
กำลังสอง ข้อได้เปรียบแบบกำลังสองของควอนตัมเหนือคลาสสิกนี้สามารถเปลี่ยนเป็นข้อได้เปรียบจริงในทาง
ปฏิบัติได้ไหม อาจจะยังไม่ได้ในเร็วๆ นี้ แต่ในอนาคตไกลๆ ใครจะรู้ แต่แม้ว่า
อัลกอริทึมของ Grover จะไม่เคยนำไปสู่ข้อได้เปรียบในทางปฏิบัติสำหรับการค้นหา มันก็ยังเป็นส่วนสำคัญของ
รากฐานของอัลกอริทึมควอนตัมที่คุ้มค่าแก่การทำความเข้าใจ ก่อนที่เราจะไปยังอัลกอริทึมของ Grover เราต้อง
พูดถึง phase query gate สั้นๆ อัลกอริทึมควอนตัมหลายตัวในโมเดลการค้นหาถูกแสดงออกมาอย่างเป็นธรรมชาติ
โดยใช้ phase query gate และเราจะเห็นว่าอัลกอริทึมของ Grover เป็นตัวอย่าง
เฉพาะ มาเริ่มด้วยมุมมองเร็วๆ ของ query gate ธรรมดาสำหรับฟังก์ชัน f ใน
รูปแบบที่เราพูดกันมา query gate UF ถูกนิยามบนสถานะพื้นฐานมาตรฐานตามที่แสดงบน
หน้าจอ และสำหรับการซ้อนทับของสถานะพื้นฐานมาตรฐาน การกระทำถูกกำหนดโดยความเป็นเชิงเส้น และควรเตือนตัวเอง
ว่าจาก Boolean circuit สำหรับ f เราสามารถสร้าง circuit สำหรับการดำเนินการ UF นี้ด้วยต้นทุนที่เป็น
เชิงเส้นกับขนาดของ Boolean circuit phase query gate สำหรับ f อีกด้านหนึ่ง ซึ่งจะเรียกว่า
ZF ทำงานแบบนี้ โดยเฉพาะ gate นี้ทำงานบน
n ตัวเล็ก qubit ไม่ใช่ n ตัวเล็กบวกหนึ่ง qubit และมันแค่เอาค่าฟังก์ชันไปใส่ใน
เฟสโดยอัตโนมัติ แทนที่จะ XOR ค่าเอาต์พุตไปยัง qubit เพิ่มเติมเหมือนที่เรามีสำหรับ
UF ดังนั้นถ้าเราคิดว่าจะเกิดอะไรขึ้นเมื่อเราใช้ phase Kickback กับ UF gate
เราก็แค่ทำ ZF gate เราต้องการสถานะลบ และมันใช้หนึ่งครั้ง
ในการประเมิน UF แต่เราได้สถานะลบกลับมาจริงๆ และสามารถใช้มันสำหรับครั้งถัดไปถ้าต้องการ หรือเราอาจ
จะทิ้งมันไปก็ได้ นั่นคือสิ่งที่ phase query gate เป็น ทีนี้ถ้าเราแค่
ได้รับ phase query gate ZF และนี่เป็นทางเดียวที่เราเข้าถึงฟังก์ชัน f ได้ เราจริงๆ ไม่สามารถ
กู้คืน UF gate ได้ แต่ถ้าเรามีเวอร์ชันควบคุมของ ZF เราก็สามารถ
สร้าง UF gate ได้ และผมจะปล่อยให้เป็น
แบบฝึกหัดของคุณ นอกจาก phase query gate สำหรับฟังก์ชัน f แล้ว เรายังต้องการ phase query gate สำหรับฟังก์ชัน OR n บิต
หรือพูดอีกอย่างก็คือฟังก์ชันที่ให้ค่าศูนย์เมื่อได้รับสตริงศูนย์ทั้งหมด และนอกจากนั้น
ให้ค่าหนึ่ง และวิธีที่ Z-OR ทำงานบนสถานะพื้นฐานมาตรฐานแสดงอยู่
ที่นี่บนหน้าจอ gate นี้ไม่มีการขึ้นอยู่กับฟังก์ชัน f ดังนั้นไม่ต้องใช้
การค้นหาใดๆ และวิธีหนึ่งที่เราสามารถสร้าง circuit ควอนตัมที่ทำการดำเนินการนี้ได้คือทำบางอย่าง
คล้ายกับที่เราทำสำหรับฟังก์ชัน f ยกเว้นว่าเราเริ่มด้วย Boolean circuit ที่คำนวณฟังก์ชัน OR บน
n บิต และตอนนี้เรามี gate เหล่านี้แล้ว เราก็พร้อมที่จะไปส่วน
ถัดไป ทีนี้เราจะพูดถึงอัลกอริทึมของ Grover เริ่มจากคำอธิบายของอัลกอริทึม เราเริ่มด้วยการเริ่มต้น
n ตัวเล็ก qubit แต่ละตัวเป็นสถานะบวก หรือพูดอีกอย่างเราใส่ qubit เหล่านี้ในสถานะซ้อนทับเท่าๆ กันของ
สตริงไบนารีทุกตัวที่มีความยาว n สิ่งที่เราจะทำคือนำทางสถานะของ qubit เหล่านี้
ไปสู่คำตอบ ดังนั้นมันก็เข้าใจได้ที่เราเริ่มในสถานะนี้เพราะเรายังไม่รู้อะไรเกี่ยวกับฟังก์ชัน f เลย
ณ จุดนี้ทุกสตริงมีโอกาสเท่าๆ กันที่จะเป็นคำตอบ และนั่นสะท้อนจากการที่ qubit เหล่านี้อยู่ในสถานะซ้อนทับเท่าๆ กันของ
ทุกสตริง แล้วเราก็ทำซ้ำ เราใช้การดำเนินการ Grover ซ้ำๆ ซึ่งเป็นหัวใจของ
อัลกอริทึม และผมจะอธิบายในอีกสักครู่ เราใช้การดำเนินการนี้ทั้งหมด T ครั้ง โดยที่ T เป็นจำนวนเต็มไม่ติดลบ
บางตัว แต่จำนวนนี้ไม่ได้ถูกกำหนดโดยอัลกอริทึมเอง เราต้องเลือก T อย่างใดอย่างหนึ่ง และในส่วน
ถัดไปเราจะพูดถึงการเลือก T ที่ดี แต่ตอนนี้เราสามารถคิดว่าจำนวนรอบ T
เป็นค่าอะไรก็ได้ และสุดท้ายเราวัดในฐานมาตรฐาน และนั่นให้
คำตอบที่เป็นไปได้ ไม่มีการรับประกันว่ามันจะเป็นคำตอบจริง แต่ถ้าเราเลือก T ดีๆ
ความน่าจะเป็นที่จะได้คำตอบก็สามารถทำให้สูงได้ และนี่คือการดำเนินการ Grover
ตัวมันเอง ซึ่งเราตั้งชื่อว่า G มันเป็นการประกอบกันของการดำเนินการทั้งหมดบน N qubit ดังนั้นนี่เป็นการดำเนินการ N
qubit ก่อนอื่นเรามี ZF gate หรือพูดอีกอย่างคือ phase query gate สำหรับ
ฟังก์ชันอินพุต f ตามด้วยชั้นของ Hadamard gate แล้วเรามี Z-OR ซึ่งเป็น phase query gate สำหรับฟังก์ชัน OR
และสุดท้ายอีกชั้นหนึ่งของ Hadamard gate เราจะเห็นว่าหนึ่งรอบการทำซ้ำใน
ขั้นตอนที่สองสามารถทำได้ด้วย circuit ที่มีรูปแบบตามที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ และตรงนี้เรามีสี่ qubit ด้วยนะ
แต่โดยทั่วไปเราสามารถมี qubit กี่ตัวก็ได้ สิ่งสำคัญที่ต้องสังเกตคือเราต้องใช้หนึ่งครั้งการค้นหา f เพื่อทำ G
เราต้องใช้หนึ่งครั้งการค้นหาเพื่อทำ ZF และการดำเนินการอื่นๆ ไม่มีการขึ้นอยู่กับ F ดังนั้นไม่ต้องใช้การค้นหา ดังนั้นจำนวน T
ที่แทนจำนวนครั้งที่เราใช้ G ในขั้นตอนที่สอง ก็แทนจำนวนครั้งการค้นหาที่เรา
ต้องการด้วย นี่เป็นวิธีทั่วไปที่เราอาจใช้อัลกอริทึมของ Grover แต่ไม่ใช่วิธีเดียวแน่นอน อย่างที่ผมพูดไว้
ก่อนหน้า สิ่งแรกที่เราต้องทำคือเลือก T และเราจะลงรายละเอียดในส่วนถัดไป
ไม่ว่า T ที่เราเลือกจะเป็นเท่าไหร่ เรารันอัลกอริทึมของ Grover สำหรับ T รอบ และเราได้คำตอบที่เป็นไปได้
X ไม่มีการรับประกันว่า X เป็นคำตอบจริง แต่เราสามารถใช้อีกหนึ่งครั้งการค้นหาเพื่อตรวจสอบว่าเรามีคำตอบหรือเปล่า แล้วเราก็
แสดงผลคำตอบนั้นและหยุด ไม่งั้นเราก็ลองใหม่ อาจจะเลือก T ค่าอื่น
แต่ไม่จำเป็น หรือเราอาจยอมแพ้และรายงานว่าไม่มีคำตอบ อย่างที่ผมพูดไว้ก่อน นี่
ไม่ใช่วิธีเดียวที่จะใช้อัลกอริทึม แต่เป็นวิธีธรรมชาติในการใช้มันกับปัญหาการค้นหา ต่อไปเราจะดูว่าการดำเนินการ Grover
ทำอะไรกับสถานะของ N qubit ที่มันกระทำ มาคิดว่า N qubit ของเราเป็น
รีจิสเตอร์เดียว ซึ่งผมจะตั้งชื่อว่า Q จำไว้ว่าสิ่งแรกที่เราทำใน
อัลกอริทึมของ Grover คือใส่ Q เข้าไปในสถานะซ้อนทับสม่ำเสมอของสตริง n บิตทั้งหมด และเราทำโดยใช้ Hadamard
gate กับ n qubit ในสถานะศูนย์ทั้งหมด จากนั้นเราทำซ้ำการดำเนินการ Grover G แล้ว
วัด มันจะช่วยถ้าเราแบ่งเซตของสตริง n บิตทั้งหมดออกเป็นสองเซต A0 และ
A1 A0 มีสตริงทั้งหมดที่ทำให้ F มีค่าเป็นศูนย์ และ A1 มีสตริงทั้งหมดที่ทำให้ F
มีค่าเป็นหนึ่ง อีกวิธีในการพูดก็คือ A1 มีคำตอบทั้งหมดของปัญหาการค้นหา
ของเรา ส่วน A0 มีสิ่งที่ไม่ใช่คำตอบทั้งหมด เราจะสนใจเป็นพิเศษ
กับสถานะควอนตัมสองสถานะ หนึ่งคือสถานะซ้อนทับสม่ำเสมอของสิ่งที่ไม่ใช่คำตอบทั้งหมด นั่นคือ ket A0 และ
อีกอันซ้อนทับสม่ำเสมอของคำตอบทั้งหมด นั่นคือ ket A1 ผมควรชี้ให้เห็นว่าคำนิยามเหล่านี้จะ
สมเหตุสมผลเฉพาะเมื่อเซตเหล่านี้ไม่ว่างเปล่า เพราะไม่งั้นเราจะรวมศูนย์สิ่งแล้วหารด้วยศูนย์ และเมื่อเรา
วิเคราะห์อัลกอริทึมของ Grover เราจะตั้งสมมติฐานนั้น เราสามารถหาได้ง่ายมากว่า
อัลกอริทึมของ Grover ทำอะไรเมื่อ f เป็นฟังก์ชันคงที่ศูนย์หรือฟังก์ชันคงที่หนึ่ง โดยถือว่าเป็นกรณีพิเศษ แต่ผมจะปล่อยให้
คุณทำเอง ไม่น่าแปลกใจที่ถ้าทุกสตริงเป็นคำตอบ เราจะได้
คำตอบเมื่อวัดจริงๆ และถ้าไม่มีคำตอบเลย เราก็จะไม่ได้คำตอบ เพราะในกรณีนั้นไม่มี
คำตอบเลย แต่เพื่อการวิเคราะห์นี้ เราจะสมมติว่าเซตทั้งสองไม่ว่างเปล่า เพื่อให้
คำนิยามของสถานะสองสถานะนี้สมเหตุสมผล สัญกรณ์นี้ค่อนข้าง
เป็นเรื่องปกติ เมื่อใดก็ตามที่เรามีเซตจำกัดที่ไม่ว่างเปล่า S เราสามารถเขียน ket S เพื่อหมายถึงสถานะซ้อนทับสม่ำเสมอของ
สมาชิกของเซตนั้น เหมือนกับที่เรามีตรงนี้ มาเก็บรวบรวมคำนิยามเหล่านี้แบบนี้ แล้วเราจะเห็นว่ามันเชื่อมโยง
กับอัลกอริทึมของ Grover อย่างไร ขั้นตอนแรกของอัลกอริทึมของ Grover คือขั้นตอนเริ่มต้นซึ่งใส่ Q เข้าไปในสถานะซ้อนทับ
สม่ำเสมอของสตริง n บิตทั้งหมด และเพื่อให้สถานะนี้มีชื่อที่จำง่าย ผมจะเรียกมันว่า
ket U U ย่อมาจาก uniform สำคัญสำหรับการวิเคราะห์ที่เราต้องสังเกตก่อนว่า
สถานะสม่ำเสมอ ket U นี้อยู่ในปริภูมิย่อยที่กางโดยเวกเตอร์สองตัว ket A0 และ ket
A1 โดยเฉพาะถ้าเราเอาส่วนผสมเชิงเส้นของสถานะสองสถานะนี้ตามที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ เราจะได้ ket
U กุญแจสำคัญของการวิเคราะห์ทั้งหมดคือข้อเท็จจริงที่ว่าสถานะของ Q ยังคงอยู่ใน
ปริภูมิย่อยสองมิตินี้ไม่ว่าเราจะใช้การดำเนินการ Grover กี่ครั้ง ดังนั้นทุกอย่างจะลดลงเหลือ
สิ่งที่เกิดขึ้นในปริภูมิย่อยสองมิติ ทีนี้มาดูว่าการดำเนินการ Grover ทำอะไร และโดยเฉพาะว่ามัน
ทำอะไรกับเวกเตอร์ในปริภูมิย่อยสองมิติที่กางโดย ket A0 และ ket
A1 จะช่วยถ้านึกว่า G แบ่งเป็นสองส่วน ส่วนหนึ่งคือ ZF
gate และอีกส่วนคือ Z-OR gate ที่อยู่ระหว่างสองชั้นของ Hadamard
gate นี่คือคำนิยามของ ZF จากก่อนหน้า และค่อนข้างตรงไปตรงมาจากคำนิยามนั้นที่จะเห็นว่า
การกระทำต่อสถานะสองสถานะของเรา สถานะซ้อนทับสม่ำเสมอของสิ่งที่ไม่ใช่คำตอบและคำตอบ คือแค่ใส่เครื่องหมายลบ
ข้างหน้า ket A1 ส่วน ket A0 ไม่มีอะไรเกิดขึ้น และนั่นคือทั้งหมดที่เราต้องรู้
เกี่ยวกับ ZF สำหรับการวิเคราะห์นี้ สำหรับส่วนที่สองซึ่งเป็น
Z-OR gate ที่อยู่ระหว่างสองชั้นของ Hadamard gate มาเริ่มด้วยการทบทวนว่า Z-OR ถูกนิยามอย่างไร วิธีหนึ่งในการเขียน
ตามที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ นี่เป็นนิพจน์เดียวกับก่อนหน้า และอีกวิธีในการแสดงโดยใช้สัญกรณ์
ไดเรกต์ก็แบบนี้ และคุณสามารถตรวจสอบนิพจน์นี้ได้โดยคิดว่าการดำเนินการทาง
ขวามือกระทำต่อสถานะพื้นฐานมาตรฐานอย่างไร โดยเฉพาะมันไม่ทำอะไรกับสถานะศูนย์ทั้งหมด และ
สถานะพื้นฐานมาตรฐานอื่นๆ ทุกตัวได้เครื่องหมายลบ ซึ่งสอดคล้องกับคำนิยามของ Z-
OR ดังนั้นถ้าเราใส่การดำเนินการนี้ระหว่างสองชั้นของ Hadamard gate เราก็ได้นิพจน์คล้ายกัน ยกเว้น
ว่าแทนที่สถานะพื้นฐานมาตรฐานศูนย์ทั้งหมด ตอนนี้เรามีสถานะซ้อนทับสม่ำเสมอ ket U และนั่นเพราะ H เทนเซอร์
n แปลงสถานะพื้นฐานมาตรฐานศูนย์ทั้งหมดเป็น ket U และ H เทนเซอร์ n ก็เป็นทรานสโพสคอนจูเกตของตัวเอง ดังนั้นมันทำงานในลักษณะ
คล้ายกันเมื่อกระทำจากขวาบน bra แทนที่จะเป็น ket และตอนนี้เราจะหา
ว่า G ทำอะไรกับเวกเตอร์สองตัว A0 และ A1 โดยใช้ข้อเท็จจริงที่เราเพิ่งสังเกต
เห็น มาเริ่มกับ A0 ก่อน มาแทนที่นิพจน์
ที่เราได้สำหรับ Z-OR gate ที่อยู่ระหว่างสองชั้นของ Hadamard gate ต่อไปเราสามารถใช้ข้อเท็จจริงที่ว่า ZF ไม่ทำอะไร
กับ ket A0 ดังนั้นเราสามารถเอาการดำเนินการ ZF ออกได้ และตอนนี้ใช้คำอธิบาย
ของ ket U ที่เรามีข้างบน ร่วมกับข้อเท็จจริงที่ว่า ket A0 และ ket A1 เป็นเวกเตอร์หน่วยที่ตั้งฉากกัน เราสามารถคำนวณ
ผลคูณของ bra นี้กับ ket นี้ และสิ่งที่ได้คือรากที่สองของจำนวนสิ่งที่ไม่ใช่คำตอบ
หารด้วย N เราสามารถใช้ข้อเท็จจริงนี้ในการคำนวณสิ่งที่ได้ และโดยการแทนค่านิพจน์ของ ket U และ
ทำให้ง่ายลง เราก็ได้ผลลัพธ์สุดท้ายตามที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ โดยเฉพาะสังเกตว่า
เวกเตอร์นี้อยู่ในปริภูมิย่อยสองมิติที่กางโดย ket A0 และ ket A1 อย่างที่ผมบอกไว้ก่อน และ
ยิ่งกว่านั้น สัมประสิทธิ์เป็นจำนวนจริง ตรวจสอบตามจังหวะของคุณเอง
ถ้าคุณเลือกที่จะทำ ผมมักจะผ่านเรื่องพวกนี้เร็วๆ ในวิดีโอเหล่านี้ โดย
คาดว่าคุณจะหยุดวิดีโอเพื่อคิดถ้าคุณเลือกที่จะทำ มาจัดระเบียบนี้เพื่อ
เก็บผลลัพธ์สุดท้ายไว้ใช้ทีหลัง และตอนนี้เราจะทำสิ่งคล้ายกันสำหรับเวกเตอร์ ket
A1 เราสามารถใช้นิพจน์เดียวกันของ G ก่อนหน้า และคราวนี้ ZF gate ใส่
เครื่องหมายลบ ซึ่งตรงนี้สะท้อนจากการที่เราสลับสองพจน์ในการดำเนินการใน
วงเล็บ จากนั้นเราดำเนินการในลักษณะคล้ายกันมาก และผลลัพธ์สุดท้ายก็คล้ายกัน ยกเว้นว่าสัมประสิทธิ์สองตัว
ถูกสลับ และตอนนี้เรามีเครื่องหมายลบข้างหน้าตัวหนึ่ง ซึ่งเป็นผลจากพีชคณิต และอีกครั้ง
คุณสามารถตรวจสอบตามจังหวะของคุณ สังเกตว่าอีกครั้งเรามีส่วนผสมเชิงเส้นจริงของเวกเตอร์สองตัว ket A0 และ
ket A1 เราจะจัดระเบียบอันนี้ด้วย แล้วใส่ผลลัพธ์สุดท้ายรวมกับอีกอัน และตอนนี้เราเห็นว่า G
กระทำต่อปริภูมิย่อยที่กางโดยเวกเตอร์สองตัวอย่างไร วิธีหนึ่งในการทำก็คือแสดงมันในรูปของเมทริกซ์ 2x2 M ที่
แสดงบนหน้าจอ และเพื่อให้ชัดเจน สิ่งที่เราทำตรงนี้คือเราเชื่อมโยงแถวแรกและคอลัมน์
แรกกับ ket A0 และแถวที่สองและคอลัมน์ที่สองกับ ket A1 จนถึงตอนนี้ในซีรีส์ เรา
แค่ใช้เมทริกซ์เพื่ออธิบายวิธีที่การดำเนินการทำงานบนสถานะพื้นฐานมาตรฐาน แต่เป็นเรื่องปกติที่จะใช้เมทริกซ์
เพื่ออธิบายการกระทำของแมปเชิงเส้นบนชุดเวกเตอร์ต่างๆ ไม่ใช่แค่สถานะพื้นฐานมาตรฐาน และตรงนี้เรากำลังพูดว่าการดำเนินการ G ทำอะไร
กับเวกเตอร์ ket A0 และ ket A1 เราสามารถพูดเพิ่มเติมเกี่ยวกับสิ่งที่ G ทำกับเวกเตอร์ใน
สแปนของ ket A0 และ ket A1 ถ้าเราดูเมทริกซ์ M นี้ใกล้ๆ และโดยเฉพาะสิ่งที่เราจะพบคือ
M เป็นเมทริกซ์การหมุน หมายความว่าการกระทำของมันต่อปริภูมิสองมิตินี้สามารถอธิบายเป็นการหมุนด้วยมุม
คงที่บางค่า มีสองสามวิธีที่จะเห็นสิ่งนี้ และวิธีหนึ่งคือสังเกต
ว่าเมทริกซ์ M นี้สามารถแสดงเป็นกำลังสองของเมทริกซ์ที่ดูเรียบง่ายกว่า มันอาจจะยากที่จะเห็นถ้า
เราแค่ดู M เฉยๆ แต่นี่ไม่ใช่สิ่งที่เราต้องค้นพบเอง เราแค่ต้องตรวจสอบ และเราทำได้โดยแค่
ยกกำลังสองเมทริกซ์ทางขวา อีกวิธีในการเขียนเมทริกซ์ทางขวาโดยไม่รวมกำลังสอง
แสดงบนหน้าจอ และนี่เป็นวิธีทั่วไปในการอธิบายการหมุนด้วยมุม Theta ที่กำหนด เป็น
เมทริกซ์ มุมที่แน่นอนที่เราหมุนคือ inverse sine ของรากที่สองของจำนวน
คำตอบหารด้วย N และอีกอย่าง เพราะนี่เป็นครั้งแรกที่เราเห็น ให้ผมชี้ให้เห็นว่า
มุมนี้สำคัญมาก มันจะปรากฏอยู่เรื่อยๆ เมื่อเราดำเนินการ
วิเคราะห์ต่อไป อาร์กิวเมนต์ของ inverse sine เป็นจำนวนระหว่าง 0 ถึง 1 และโดยเฉพาะวิธีที่เรา
ตีความ inverse sine ตรงนี้คือ มันเป็นมุมระหว่าง 0 ถึง Pi / 2 ที่ให้อาร์กิวเมนต์เมื่อเรา
หาค่า sine นั่นคือวิธีหนึ่งในการคิดเกี่ยวกับเมทริกซ์นี้ที่เรายกกำลังสองเพื่อให้ได้
M และเพราะการยกกำลังสองเมทริกซ์เหมือนกับการใช้มันสองครั้ง เราเห็นว่า M สามารถเขียนเป็น
การหมุนไม่ใช่ด้วยมุม Theta แต่ด้วย 2 คูณ Theta เพราะการยกกำลังสองทำให้เราหมุนด้วยมุม Theta
สองครั้ง อีกวิธีในการตรวจสอบทั้งหมดนี้ ในกรณีที่เป็นประโยชน์ คือเริ่มจากนิพจน์สุดท้ายของ M
แล้วใช้สูตรมุมสองเท่าจากตรีโกณมิติเพื่อให้ได้นิพจน์เดิมของ
M และนี่คือนิพจน์ของ M ที่อธิบายการกระทำของ G ต่อปริภูมิย่อยที่กางโดย ket A0 และ ket A1 ที่
จะมีประโยชน์มากที่สุดต่อไป กลับมาที่อัลกอริทึมของ Grover หลังจาก
ขั้นตอนเริ่มต้น แต่ก่อนที่เราจะใช้ G สถานะของรีจิสเตอร์ N qubit Q ของเราคือ ket U คือ
สถานะซ้อนทับสม่ำเสมอของสตริง n บิตทั้งหมด และตรงนี้เรามีนิพจน์เดียวกันของ ket U ในรูปของ ket A0 และ
ket A1 เหมือนก่อน แต่ตอนนี้ที่เราระบุมุม Theta ได้แล้ว เราเห็นว่า
สามารถเขียน ket U เป็น cosine Theta คูณ ket A0 บวก sine Theta คูณ ket
A1 นั่นชัดเจนสำหรับสัมประสิทธิ์ของ ket A1 และสำหรับสัมประสิทธิ์อีกตัว เราแค่ต้องสังเกตว่าขนาดของ A0 บวก
ขนาดของ A1 เป็น N แล้วเราก็ได้มันจากตรีโกณมิติพื้นฐาน นั่นคือสถานะที่เรา
เริ่มต้น และครั้งแรกที่เราใช้ G เราหมุนด้วยมุม 2 คูณ Theta ดังนั้นมุมรวมจะเป็น 3 คูณ
Theta และถ้าเราใช้ G อีกครั้ง มุมจะเพิ่มเป็น 5 Theta เพราะเราหมุนเพิ่มด้วย
มุม 2 Theta เพิ่มเติม และต่อไปเรื่อยๆ ดังนั้นหลังจากใช้ G T ครั้ง เราสามารถแสดง
สถานะที่ได้ตามที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ โดยมุมของสถานะเท่ากับ 2T + 1 คูณ Theta นั่นคือ 2 คูณ Theta
สำหรับแต่ละครั้งที่ใช้ G พร้อมกับ Theta เพิ่มเติมเพราะนั่นคือสถานะที่เราเริ่ม
เรายังสามารถคิดเกี่ยวกับการกระทำของการดำเนินการ Grover ในเชิงเรขาคณิต และนี่ช่วยให้เข้าใจว่า
มันทำงานอย่างไรและทำไมผลของมันคือการหมุนสถานะของรีจิสเตอร์ Q นี่คือแนวคิดหลัก การดำเนินการ
Grover เป็นการประกอบกันของสองส่วนที่เราระบุไว้แล้ว ส่วนหนึ่งคือ ZF และอีกส่วนคือ Z-OR ที่อยู่ระหว่าง
สองชั้นของ Hadamard gate สองส่วนนี้เป็น
การสะท้อน และเมื่อเราประกอบสองการสะท้อนเข้าด้วยกัน เราจะได้การหมุน มาดูว่ามันทำงานยังไงใน
รายละเอียด ก่อนอื่นมาโฟกัสที่ ZF และเราจะจำกัดความสนใจของเราไว้ที่
ปริภูมิย่อยสองมิติเดียวกับที่เราพูดกันมา คือที่กางโดย ket A0 และ ket
A1 อย่างที่เราสังเกตไว้แล้ว การกระทำของ ZF บนปริภูมินี้ค่อนข้างง่าย มันไม่ทำอะไร
กับ ket A0 และใส่เครื่องหมายลบข้างหน้า ket A1 นี่เป็นการสะท้อน และโดยเฉพาะ
มันเป็นการสะท้อนรอบเส้นที่ขนานกับ ket A0 ซึ่งเราจะเรียกว่า L1 เพื่อให้มีชื่อ
เพื่อให้เห็นว่าทำไมมันเป็นการสะท้อน มันช่วยถ้าวาดรูป ตรงนี้เรามีเวกเตอร์สองตัว ket
A0 และ ket A1 ซึ่งเป็นเวกเตอร์หน่วยที่ตั้งฉากกัน และเราสามารถคิดว่าหน้าจอประกอบด้วยส่วนผสมเชิงเส้นจริง
ทั้งหมดของเวกเตอร์สองตัวนี้ ดังนั้นวงกลมแทนเวกเตอร์หน่วยทั้งหมดที่สัมประสิทธิ์ของ
เวกเตอร์สองตัวนี้เป็นจำนวนจริง นี่คือเส้น L1 ที่ขนานกับ ket A0 และถ้าเราพิจารณา
เวกเตอร์ S ใดๆ บนวงกลมนี้ ผลของการใช้ ZF คือสะท้อนรอบเส้นนี้ ตามที่แสดงบน
หน้าจอ เพราะเราไม่ทำอะไรกับ ket A0 และเราใส่เครื่องหมายลบข้างหน้า ket
A1 ในกรณีพิเศษที่ S คือ ket A0 ไม่มีอะไรเกิดขึ้นเมื่อเราทำการสะท้อนนี้ และเมื่อ S คือ
ket A1 การสะท้อนพาเราไปจนถึง ลบ ket A1 และนั่นสอดคล้องกับการกระทำของ ZF ดังนั้น ZF เป็น
การสะท้อนที่สามารถมองเห็นได้ตามที่เรามีตรงนี้ ส่วนที่สองของ G ซึ่งเป็น Z-OR
ที่อยู่ระหว่างสองชั้นของ Hadamard gate สามารถแสดงเป็น 2 คูณ ket U bra U ลบเมทริกซ์เอกลักษณ์ ตามที่เรา
เห็นแล้ว และอีกครั้งนี่เป็นการสะท้อน คราวนี้รอบเส้น L2 ที่ขนานกับ ket U แทนที่จะเป็น ket
A0 เราสามารถมองเห็นการดำเนินการนี้ในลักษณะคล้ายกับ ZF นี่คือเวกเตอร์ ket U
สมมติ ดังนั้นนี่คือเส้น L2 ที่ขนานกับ ket U และอีกครั้งการกระทำต่อเวกเตอร์ S ใดๆ คือสะท้อน
มันรอบเส้น ซึ่งในกรณีนี้คือ L2
และสุดท้าย อย่างที่ผมบอก เมื่อใดก็ตามที่เราประกอบสองการสะท้อน เราจะได้การหมุน และโดยเฉพาะมันเป็น
การหมุนด้วยสองเท่าของมุมระหว่างเส้นสะท้อน มาวาดรูป
คล้ายกับก่อนหน้า นี่คือเส้นสะท้อนที่มีมุม Theta ระหว่าง
กัน และถ้าเราเอาเวกเตอร์ S ใดๆ สะท้อนรอบเส้นแรก L1 แล้ว
สะท้อนรอบเส้นที่สอง L2 ผลลัพธ์สุทธิจะเป็นการหมุนเวกเตอร์ S ด้วยมุมสองเท่าของ Theta
และนี่เป็นสิ่งที่เป็นจริงโดยทั่วไป และคุณสามารถลองกับตัวอย่างเพิ่มเติมของคุณเองเพื่อดูว่ามันเป็นแบบนี้จริงๆ
อยู่แล้ว หวังว่านี่จะช่วยให้คุณได้สัญชาตญาณว่าทำไมการดำเนินการ Grover ถึงมีผลเป็นการหมุน
เวกเตอร์ ต่อไปเราจะพูดถึงเรื่องการเลือกจำนวนรอบ T ในอัลกอริทึมของ
Grover มาเริ่มด้วยการคิดว่าการวิเคราะห์ที่เราเห็นจนถึงตอนนี้ ซึ่งเปิดเผยว่าการดำเนินการ Grover ทำอะไร
เมื่อเราใช้มันซ้ำๆ กับสถานะซ้อนทับสม่ำเสมอ เชื่อมโยงกับงานที่เราหวังจะแก้อย่างไร ซึ่งก็คือหาคำตอบของปัญหาการค้นหา
หรือพูดอีกอย่างคือสตริงใดๆ ที่อยู่ในเซต A1 สรุปสั้นๆ เราจะตั้ง
เป้าหมายแล้วหาว่าต้องใช้การดำเนินการ Grover กี่ครั้งเพื่อเข้าใกล้เป้าหมาย
นั้น ก่อนอื่นสมมติว่าเรามีสถานะใดๆ ที่เป็นส่วนผสมเชิงเส้นของเวกเตอร์สองตัว ket A0 และ ket
A1 ถ้าเราวัดสถานะนี้ในฐานมาตรฐาน เราจะได้ผลลัพธ์ในเซต A1 ซึ่ง
เป็นเซตของคำตอบของปัญหาการค้นหา ด้วยความน่าจะเป็นเท่ากับค่าสัมบูรณ์ยกกำลังสองของสัมประสิทธิ์ที่เรามีสำหรับ ket A1 และสำหรับ
เวกเตอร์ที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ สัมประสิทธิ์นั้นคือ beta นี่เข้าใจได้ง่าย ถ้าเราวัดสถานะ ket A0
เราจะได้สิ่งที่ไม่ใช่คำตอบแบบสุ่ม และถ้าเราวัด ket A1 เราจะได้คำตอบแบบสุ่ม ดังนั้นถ้าเราวัดสถานะ
ตรงนี้ เราจะได้สิ่งที่ไม่ใช่คำตอบแบบสุ่มด้วยความน่าจะเป็น ค่าสัมบูรณ์ของ alpha ยกกำลังสอง และคำตอบแบบสุ่ม
ด้วยความน่าจะเป็น ค่าสัมบูรณ์ของ beta ยกกำลังสอง แต่เราก็สามารถคำนวณจริงๆ ได้ นี่คือสถานะเขียนออกมา
เพื่อให้เราเห็นว่าค่าของเวกเตอร์นี้สำหรับสถานะพื้นฐานมาตรฐานเป็นอย่างไร ดังนั้นถ้าเราวัด นี่คือ
ความน่าจะเป็นที่จะได้แต่ละผลลัพธ์ที่เป็นไปได้ และเพื่อให้ได้ความน่าจะเป็นที่จะได้คำตอบ เรารวม
ความน่าจะเป็นของคำตอบที่เป็นไปได้ทั้งหมด ซึ่งให้ค่าสัมบูรณ์ของ beta ยกกำลังสอง ตามที่
คาดไว้ ทีนี้เราวิเคราะห์ไปแล้วว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้นเมื่อเรารันอัลกอริทึมของ Grover T รอบ เราได้สถานะที่
แสดงบนหน้าจอ ดังนั้นเพราะสัมประสิทธิ์ของ ket A1 คือ sine
ของ 2T + 1 คูณ Theta โดยที่อีกครั้งตรงนี้คือมุม Theta ที่สำคัญมาก เรา
จะเห็นคำตอบด้วยความน่าจะเป็น sine ยกกำลังสอง ของ 2T + 1 คูณ
Theta เราอยากให้ความน่าจะเป็นนั้นสูง ในอุดมคติใกล้หนึ่งมากที่สุด ดังนั้นขณะที่เราหมุนเวกเตอร์
สถานะโดยทำ G ซ้ำ เราจะคิดว่า ket A1 เป็นสถานะเป้าหมาย และเราจะพยายาม
เลือก T เพื่อให้เราไปใกล้สถานะนี้ และขณะทำ ต้องจำไว้ว่าเราอยากลด
T ให้น้อยที่สุดด้วย เพราะนั่นคือจำนวนครั้งการค้นหาที่เราต้องทำ ดังนั้นถ้าเราอยากให้
ความน่าจะเป็นนี้ใกล้หนึ่ง และลด T ให้น้อยที่สุด มันก็สมเหตุสมผลที่จะทำให้มุมของเวกเตอร์สถานะใกล้ Pi / 2 เพราะ
นั่นเป็นมุมที่เล็กที่สุดที่ทำให้กำลังสองของ sine มีค่ามาก มันก็เป็นโอกาสแรกที่จะทำให้ความน่าจะเป็นสูงขณะที่เรา
หมุนเวกเตอร์สถานะ ทีนี้เราไม่จำเป็นต้องไปถึงมุม Pi / 2 ตรงเป๊ะ เพราะ T ต้อง
เป็นจำนวนเต็ม แต่ถ้าเราคิดแบบประมาณและแก้หา T เสมือนว่าเป็นอสมการ เราจะเห็นว่าในอุดมคติ
การเลือก T เป็น Pi / 4 คูณ Theta ลบ 1/2 นั้น
สมเหตุสมผล แต่แน่นอนว่า T ต้องเป็นจำนวนเต็มไม่ติดลบ ดังนั้นสิ่งที่เราทำคือ
เอาจำนวนเต็มที่ใกล้ที่สุดกับค่าในอุดมคตินี้ ซึ่งก็คือ floor ของ Pi หาร 4 คูณ
Theta การหา floor ก็แค่หมายความว่าเราตัดส่วนทศนิยมออก พูดอีกอย่างก็คือเป็นจำนวนเต็มที่มากที่สุด
ที่น้อยกว่าหรือเท่ากับสิ่งที่เราหา floor ตามนิพจน์นี้ ถ้า
ค่าในอุดมคติบังเอิญอยู่ตรงกลางระหว่างจำนวนเต็มพอดี เราจะปัดขึ้น แต่นั่นจะไม่มีผลอะไรเลยสำหรับ
บทเรียนนี้ ต่อจากนี้เราจะโฟกัสที่การเลือก T แบบนี้โดยเฉพาะ
แต่มีอีกสิ่งสำคัญที่เราต้องพิจารณา ซึ่งก็คือการกำหนด T นี้ขึ้นอยู่กับ
จำนวนคำตอบที่มี เพราะมุม Theta ขึ้นอยู่กับจำนวน
คำตอบ ต่อจากนี้ผมจะใช้ตัวอักษร S เพื่อแทนจำนวนคำตอบ หรือพูดอีกอย่างก็คือขนาดของ
เซต A1 เพื่อความสะดวก อย่างไรก็ตาม ประเด็นก็คือ
นิพจน์ของ T ค่าที่เราตั้งสมมติฐานว่าน่าจะดี ขึ้นอยู่กับ Theta และ Theta ขึ้นอยู่กับ S ซึ่งคือ
ขนาดของเซต A1 นี่ไม่เป็นปัญหาถ้าเรารู้ล่วงหน้าว่ามีคำตอบกี่ตัว แต่
ถ้าเราไม่รู้ว่ามีกี่คำตอบล่วงหน้า เราก็ไม่รู้ว่า Theta เป็นเท่าไหร่ ดังนั้นเราเลือก T แบบนี้ไม่ได้
และเราจะต้องทำอย่างอื่น ผมจะกลับมาที่สถานการณ์ที่เราไม่รู้ S ทีหลัง แต่
ก่อนอื่นมาโฟกัสที่สถานการณ์ที่เรารู้ว่ามีคำตอบกี่ตัว เริ่มจากการค้นหาแบบคำตอบเดียว
ที่มีการรับประกันว่ามีคำตอบเดียวที่เราตาม
หา ผมเคยพูดถึงปัญหาการค้นหาแบบคำตอบเดียวเป็นตัวอย่างของปัญหาการค้นหาในบทเรียน
ที่ห้า อินพุตคือฟังก์ชัน f จาก n บิตไปหนึ่งบิต มีสตริง n บิตเดียว
ที่ทำให้ F มีค่าเป็นหนึ่ง และเป้าหมายคือแสดงผลสตริงนั้น
นี่เทียบเท่ากับปัญหาการค้นหาแบบไม่มีโครงสร้างที่เราพูดกันมา แต่มีเงื่อนไขว่ามีคำตอบเดียวเท่านั้น และจริงๆ แล้วนี่คือ
เวอร์ชันเดียวของปัญหาการค้นหาที่ Lov Grover พิจารณาในบทความต้นฉบับปี 1996 ที่แนะนำอัลกอริทึมของ
Grover สำหรับการค้นหาแบบคำตอบเดียว เรามี S เท่ากับ 1 และดังนั้นมุม Theta ที่สำคัญนี้เท่ากับ inverse sine
ของรากที่สองของ 1/N เมื่อ N มีค่ามาก ค่านี้ประมาณรากที่สองของ 1/N และ
นั่นเพราะสำหรับมุมที่เล็กลงเรื่อยๆ ฟังก์ชัน sine เริ่มดูเหมือนฟังก์ชัน
เอกลักษณ์มากขึ้น ถ้าเราแทนค่าประมาณนั้นในการเลือก T เราจะเห็นว่า T ประมาณ floor
ของ Pi / 4 คูณรากที่สองของ N นั่นดี เพราะเราอยู่บนเส้นทางที่จะใช้ Big O ของรากที่สองของ N
ครั้งการค้นหา แม้ว่าตอนนี้เรายังไม่ได้ดูว่าอัลกอริทึมทำงานได้ดีแค่ไหน
มาดูตัวอย่างที่ N ตัวใหญ่เป็น 128 ซึ่งคือ 2 ยกกำลัง 7 ดังนั้น
ฟังก์ชัน f ของเราจาก 7 บิตไปหนึ่งบิต และเราสมมติว่ามีคำตอบเดียว แต่เพื่อหาว่า
อัลกอริทึมทำงานได้ดีแค่ไหน เราต้องสนใจแค่มุม Theta ซึ่งเราคำนวณได้ มัน
ประมาณ 0.0885 เรเดียน ซึ่งมากกว่า 5 องศาเล็กน้อย และถ้าเราแทนค่านั้นใน
นิพจน์ของ T เราได้แปด ดังนั้นเรากำลังคิดเรื่องการค้นหาคำตอบเดียวจาก 128
ความเป็นไปได้ โดยใช้แปดครั้งการค้นหา เราสามารถวาดรูปเพื่อแสดงว่าสถานะเปลี่ยนอย่างไร
ตามเวลาเมื่อเราทำรอบการดำเนินการ Grover เหมือนเดิมเรามีสถานะ ket
A0 และ ket A1 และในกรณีนี้คือการค้นหาแบบคำตอบเดียว ket A1 จริงๆ แล้วเป็นสถานะพื้นฐานมาตรฐาน
ที่ตรงกับคำตอบเดียว ไม่ว่าจะเป็นอะไร ส่วน ket A0 เป็นสถานะซ้อนทับสม่ำเสมอของ
สตริงทั้งหมดยกเว้นคำตอบเดียว นี่คือสถานะซ้อนทับสม่ำเสมอของสตริงทั้งหมด ซึ่ง
เราเขียนเป็น cosine Theta ket A0 บวก sine Theta ket A1 และมันสมเหตุสมผลที่ ket A0
กับ ket U ใกล้กันในกรณีนี้ เพราะอย่างที่เราสังเกตเมื่อกี้ ket A0 คือ
เกือบจะเป็นสถานะซ้อนทับสม่ำเสมอของสตริงทั้งหมด มีสตริงเดียวที่หายไปคือคำตอบเดียว การใช้ G อีกครั้งหมุนเพิ่มอีก
2 Theta ดังนั้นนี่คือตำแหน่งหลังจากสองรอบ นี่สาม สี่ ห้า หก เจ็ด และแปด
และตอนนี้เราเห็นว่าเราอยู่ใกล้ ket A1 มาก ดังนั้นถ้าเราหยุดและวัดตรงนี้ เราน่าจะได้
คำตอบเดียว และจริงๆ ในกรณีนี้มีโอกาสแค่ประมาณครึ่งเปอร์เซ็นต์ที่เราจะไม่ได้คำตอบ
เดียว ในทางกลับกัน ถ้าเราใช้การดำเนินการ Grover ต่อไปมากกว่าแปดรอบที่แนะนำ
ความน่าจะเป็นที่จะได้คำตอบก็จะลดลง และเมื่อเวลาผ่านไปมันจะแกว่งไปมาเมื่อสถานะวนรอบ
วงกลม ดังนั้นสำคัญที่เราหยุดรอบการทำซ้ำในเวลาที่เหมาะสมถ้าเราอยากสำเร็จด้วยความน่าจะเป็น
สูง มาคิดเรื่องความน่าจะเป็นที่การเลือก T ของเราจะเปิดเผยคำตอบเดียว โดยทั่วไปสำหรับค่า
N ต่างๆ เราจะเขียน p(N,1) เพื่อแทนความน่าจะเป็นที่อัลกอริทึมของ Grover จะสำเร็จในการหาคำตอบเดียว
สำหรับแต่ละค่า N ที่เป็นไปได้ หนึ่งหมายถึงหนึ่งคำตอบ และเราจะขยายสัญกรณ์นี้ไปยังจำนวนคำตอบอื่นๆ
ในไม่ช้า นี่คือตารางความน่าจะเป็นเหล่านี้สำหรับค่ายกกำลังสองเล็กๆ เริ่มที่ N=2 และ
ความน่าจะเป็นคือ 1/2 ซึ่งไม่ค่อยดี แต่สำหรับ N=4 ความน่าจะเป็นเป็นหนึ่งพอดี ดังนั้นจริงๆ แล้วมัน
ทำงานได้สมบูรณ์แบบในกรณีนี้ เป็นแบบฝึกหัดที่ดีมากที่จะลองดูว่ากรณีทั้งสองนี้ทำงานอย่างไร
โดยเฉพาะกรณีที่ N เท่ากับสี่ ในกรณีนั้นเราค้นหาคำตอบเดียวจากสี่ความเป็นไปได้
เราต้องใช้แค่หนึ่งครั้งการค้นหาและมันทำงานได้สมบูรณ์แบบ เมื่อ N ใหญ่ขึ้น เราเห็นความผันผวนบ้าง ความน่าจะเป็น
ขึ้นลงเล็กน้อย แต่ดูเหมือนจะเข้าใกล้หนึ่ง และนั่นเป็นจริง สามารถพิสูจน์ได้
เชิงวิเคราะห์ว่าความน่าจะเป็นอย่างน้อยเสมอ 1 - 1/N ดังนั้นก็ดี
อัลกอริทึมไม่สมบูรณ์แบบ ไม่ได้รับประกันว่าจะได้คำตอบ แต่ก็มีโอกาสค่อนข้างสูง โดยเฉพาะสำหรับค่า
N ที่มาก รวมถึงความผิดปกติที่น่าสนใจที่เกิดขึ้นเมื่อ N เท่ากับ 4
ผมควรชี้ให้เห็นด้วยว่าเราสามารถรันอัลกอริทึมทั้งหมด รวมถึงการวัด กี่ครั้งก็ได้ที่เราเลือก และถ้ารอบใดรอบหนึ่ง
สำเร็จ เราก็จะได้คำตอบ ดังนั้นถ้าความน่าจะเป็นเหล่านี้ไม่ดีพอ เราสามารถเพิ่มมันได้โดยแค่รัน
อัลกอริทึมอีกครั้ง จริงๆ แม้ว่าความน่าจะเป็นเหล่านี้จะเท่ากับ 1/2 ทั้งหมด เราก็ยังมี
อัลกอริทึมการค้นหาที่มีประโยชน์ ทีนี้มาดูว่าจะเกิดอะไรขึ้นเมื่อมีคำตอบ
หลายตัว เราจะเริ่มด้วยตัวอย่างคล้ายกับก่อนหน้า อีกครั้ง N เท่ากับ 128 แต่คราวนี้
จำนวนคำตอบ S คือสี่แทนที่จะเป็นหนึ่ง อีกครั้งเราคำนวณ Theta กับ T ได้ และ
เราได้ว่า Theta ประมาณ 0.1777 หรือมากกว่า 10 องศาเล็กน้อย และ T เป็น
สี่คราวนี้ ดังนั้นมุมประมาณสองเท่าของตัวอย่างก่อน และ T เป็นครึ่งหนึ่งของที่
เคยเป็น เราสามารถวาดรูปเหมือนก่อน นี่คือจุดที่เรา
เริ่ม นี่หนึ่งรอบ สอง สาม และสี่ คราวนี้เราอยู่ใกล้ ket
A1 มาก และความน่าจะเป็นที่จะได้คำตอบคราวนี้มากกว่า
99.9% แต่ถ้าเราไม่รู้ดีกว่านี้ และคิดว่ามีคำตอบแค่ตัวเดียว เราจะให้ T เป็น 8 เหมือน
ก่อน เราจะหมุนเกือบรอบวงจนถึงลบ ket A0 และนั่นจะนำไปสู่ความน่าจะเป็นที่ต่ำมากของ
ความสำเร็จ นั่นเป็นตัวอย่างเพิ่มเติมที่แสดงว่ามีการเลือก T ที่ดีและการเลือก T ที่ไม่ดี และตรงนี้เราเห็น
ว่าการเลือกที่ดีสำหรับ S เท่ากับ 1 กลายเป็นการเลือกที่แย่มากสำหรับ S เท่ากับ 4 แต่สมมติว่าเรารู้ S ล่วงหน้า
และเลือก T ตามที่เรากำหนดไว้ ปรากฏว่าอัลกอริทึมของ Grover จะหาคำตอบ
ด้วยความน่าจะเป็นอย่างน้อย 1 - S/N และบ่อยครั้งมันจะมากกว่านั้นมาก มันก็อย่างน้อย S/N ด้วย แต่
นั่นน่าสนใจน้อยกว่ามาก สิ่งที่น่าสนใจกว่าคือเมื่อสัดส่วน S/N เล็กลง ขอบเขต
ของความน่าจะเป็นที่จะสำเร็จก็เข้าใกล้หนึ่งมากขึ้น อย่างที่ผมพูดไป
หลายครั้งแล้ว จำนวน T แทนไม่เพียงแค่จำนวนรอบของการดำเนินการ Grover ที่เราทำ แต่ยังเป็นจำนวน
ครั้งการค้นหาที่เราทำ แล้วจำนวนนี้ขึ้นอยู่กับ S และ
N อย่างไร ก่อนอื่นเริ่มจากข้อเท็จจริงที่ว่า inverse sine ของ X อย่างน้อยเท่ากับ X เสมอ โดยที่ X อยู่ระหว่าง 0 ถึง 1
นั่นพิสูจน์ได้ไม่ยากถ้าคุณรู้อนุกรมเทย์เลอร์ของฟังก์ชัน inverse sine แต่มีวิธีอื่นที่จะคิดด้วย และเราจะ
ยอมรับมันเพราะมันเป็นจริง นั่นหมายความว่า Theta อย่างน้อยเท่ากับรากที่สองของ S/
N และด้วยเหตุนี้ T อย่างมากเท่ากับ Pi / 4 คูณรากที่สองของ N/
S ดังนั้นนั่นดีกว่า Big O ของรากที่สองของ N อีก ยิ่ง S มากเมื่อ
เทียบกับ N เราก็ยิ่งต้องใช้ครั้งการค้นหาน้อยลง และในทางหนึ่งก็ไม่น่าแปลกใจที่สัดส่วนนี้ปรากฏ
แบบนี้ เพราะส่วนกลับของมันนิยาม Theta และท้ายที่สุด Theta คือทุกอย่างที่สำคัญสำหรับ
การวิเคราะห์นี้ อย่างที่เราเพิ่งเห็น อัลกอริทึมของ Grover ทำงานได้ค่อนข้างดีเมื่อเรารู้
ล่วงหน้าว่ามีคำตอบกี่ตัว แต่ถ้าเราไม่รู้ว่ามีคำตอบกี่ตัว
ล่ะ มีวิธีง่ายๆ อย่างหนึ่งคือแค่เลือกจำนวนรอบ
แบบสุ่ม และโดยเฉพาะการเลือก T สม่ำเสมอแบบสุ่มระหว่างหนึ่งถึง floor ของ Pi / 4 คูณรากที่สองของ N เป็น
วิธีที่ค่อนข้างดี ขีดจำกัดบนของช่วงนี้คร่าวๆ คือจำนวนครั้งการค้นหาที่เราจะเลือกสำหรับการค้นหาแบบคำตอบเดียว และจริงๆ แล้ว
มันเป็นจำนวนที่ถูกต้องในกรณีส่วนใหญ่ นี่คือเมื่อมุม Theta เล็กที่สุดเท่าที่จะเป็นไปได้ ยกเว้น
กรณีเล็กๆ ที่ไม่มีคำตอบเลย แนวคิดตรงนี้คือแทนที่จะเล็งเวกเตอร์สถานะไปที่
ket A1 อย่างระมัดระวังเหมือนที่เราทำตอนที่รู้จำนวนคำตอบ เราก็แค่หมุนด้วยมุมสุ่ม เหมือนกับ
แค่หมุนเวกเตอร์สถานะแบบสุ่ม ถ้าบังเอิญมีคำตอบแค่ตัวเดียว การหมุนสุ่มอาจดัน
เวกเตอร์สถานะใกล้ ket A1 แต่มันก็อาจไปได้แค่ส่วนหนึ่ง และถ้าบังเอิญมีคำตอบมาก
การหมุนสุ่มอาจส่งเวกเตอร์สถานะวนรอบวงกลมหลายรอบ ดังนั้นเราไม่คาดว่ามันจะเปิดเผย
คำตอบด้วยความน่าจะเป็นใกล้หนึ่ง แต่โอกาสที่จะได้คำตอบถ้ามีอยู่นั้น
ค่อนข้างดี อย่างน้อย 40% เสมอ มันไม่ชัดเจนก็จริง แต่มัน
เป็นเช่นนั้น มันไม่น่าตกใจแน่นอน เพราะมุมสุ่มจริงๆ จะมี 50% โอกาสในการหา
คำตอบอยู่แล้ว 40% ก็ไม่เลว และจำไว้ว่าเราสามารถเพิ่มความน่าจะเป็นในการหาคำตอบได้โดย
ทำซ้ำกระบวนการ โดยเลือก T อย่างอิสระแต่ละครั้ง โดยทำแบบนี้ โอกาสที่จะไม่
หาคำตอบเมื่อมีอยู่จะลดลงแบบเอ็กซ์โพเนนเชียลตามจำนวนครั้งที่ทำซ้ำ ดังนั้นถ้าเราอยากได้ 99%
โอกาสในการหาคำตอบ สิ่งที่เราทำได้คือรันวิธีง่ายๆ นี้ 10 ครั้ง อีกครั้งโดยเลือก T อย่างอิสระแต่ละ
ครั้ง โดยธรรมชาติ ถ้าเราไม่เจอคำตอบ เราก็แสดงผลว่าไม่มีคำตอบ ถ้าไม่มีคำตอบ
เราก็จะไม่เจอ ดังนั้นในกรณีนั้นเราจะแสดงผลคำตอบที่ถูกต้องเสมอซึ่งก็คือไม่มีคำตอบ ถ้ามีคำตอบ
เราอาจหาไม่เจอและประกาศผิดว่าไม่มีคำตอบ แต่ความน่าจะเป็นที่จะเกิดแบบนั้นสามารถทำให้เล็กมากได้
เรายังมี อย่างที่ผมพูดไปเมื่อกี้ ว่าต้องใช้จำนวนครั้งการค้นหาหรือการประเมิน f ที่เป็น Big O ของรากที่สอง
ของ N ดังนั้นโดยใช้อัลกอริทึมของ Grover เรายังสามารถแก้ปัญหาการค้นหาด้วยความน่าจะเป็นสูงด้วย Big O ของรากที่สองของ N
ครั้งการค้นหา แม้ว่าเราจะไม่รู้ล่วงหน้าว่ามีคำตอบกี่ตัว ยังมีวิธีที่ซับซ้อนกว่า
ที่สามารถลดจำนวนครั้งการค้นหาเมื่อจำนวนคำตอบเพิ่มขึ้น ผมจะไม่อธิบายมัน
ในรายละเอียด แต่จะโฟกัสแค่แนวคิดหลัก เราเริ่มด้วย T ตัวใหญ่เท่ากับ
หนึ่ง จากนั้นเรารันอัลกอริทึมของ Grover ด้วยจำนวนรอบสุ่ม แต่ขีดจำกัดบนคือ T ดังนั้นครั้ง
แรกที่ไปถึงขั้นตอนที่สอง เราจะรันอัลกอริทึมของ Grover ด้วยหนึ่งรอบ แต่ T จะ
เพิ่มขึ้น ถ้าเราหาคำตอบเจอเราก็แสดงผลและหยุด และถ้าไม่เจอเราก็ทำให้ T
ใหญ่ขึ้นแล้วลองอีก และเมื่อถึงจุดหนึ่งก่อนที่ T จะใหญ่เกินไป เราจะยุติกระบวนการและ
ประกาศว่าไม่มีคำตอบ มันเป็นแนวคิดพื้นฐานเดียวกับวิธีง่ายๆ ที่เรา
หมุนเวกเตอร์สถานะแบบสุ่มนั่นแหละ แต่ตรงนี้เราเริ่มด้วยการหมุนเบาๆ ก่อน โดยที่ T
เล็ก ในกรณีที่มีคำตอบมาก ด้วยวิธีนี้เราจะไม่เสียครั้งการค้นหาโดยทำให้สถานะวนรอบ
วงกลมซ้ำแล้วซ้ำเล่าโดยการหมุนแรงเกินไป แต่ถ้ามันไม่ได้ผลคือเราหาคำตอบไม่เจอ เราก็ลองอีก
แต่หมุนแรงขึ้นอีกนิด หรืออาจจะแรงขึ้น เพื่อให้มันได้ผล อัตราการเพิ่มของ
T ต้องถูกเลือกอย่างระมัดระวัง และวิธีหนึ่งที่ทำให้ได้ผลคือแทนที่ T ด้วย ceiling ของ 5/4 คูณ T
ดังนั้น T เพิ่มแบบเอ็กซ์โพเนนเชียล และเราสามารถคิดได้ว่าหมุนแรงขึ้น 25% แต่ละ
ครั้ง และมันสำคัญสำหรับการวิเคราะห์ที่ T เพิ่มแบบเอ็กซ์โพเนนเชียลแบบนี้ ทำไม 5/4 คุณอาจถาม ก็มันแค่
เป็นจำนวนที่ใช้ได้ และจริงๆ มีช่วงของค่าที่ใช้ได้ แต่สองใช้ไม่ได้ การเพิ่ม T เป็นสองเท่า
แต่ละครั้งเร็วเกินไปที่จะใช้ประโยชน์เต็มที่จากการหมุนเบาๆ อย่างไรก็ตาม ประเด็นของวิธี
ที่ซับซ้อนกว่านี้คือมันให้ขอบเขตเชิงอะซิมป์โทติกเดียวกันของจำนวนครั้งการค้นหาที่ต้องใช้ เหมือนที่เรามีก่อนหน้า
Big O ของรากที่สองของ N/S แต่เราไม่ต้องรู้ล่วงหน้าว่ามีคำตอบกี่ตัว และอีกอย่าง
เราสามารถหยุดกระบวนการนี้เมื่อ T ถึงรากที่สองของ N ดังนั้นถ้าไม่มีคำตอบ เราจะถึงข้อสรุปนั้นหลังจาก Big O
ของรากที่สองของ N ครั้งการค้นหา และนั่นคือวิธีที่เราเลือกจำนวนรอบในอัลกอริทึมของ Grover เพื่อปิดท้ายบทเรียน ผม
จะพูดข้อสังเกตสั้นๆ ไม่กี่ข้อเกี่ยวกับอัลกอริทึมของ Grover ข้อแรก ในโมเดลการค้นหา
อัลกอริทึมของ Grover เป็นอัลกอริทึมที่ดีที่สุดเชิงอะซิมป์โทติก หมายความว่าไม่สามารถคิด
อัลกอริทึมการค้นหาสำหรับแก้ปัญหาการค้นหา หรือแม้แต่ปัญหาการค้นหาแบบคำตอบเดียวโดยเฉพาะ ที่ใช้เชิงอะซิมป์โทติก
น้อยกว่า Big O ของรากที่สองของ N ครั้งการค้นหาในกรณีที่แย่ที่สุด นั่นเป็นสิ่งที่พิสูจน์ได้อย่างเข้มงวด
และจริงๆ มีการพิสูจน์ที่เป็นที่รู้จักหลายอัน น่าสนใจที่เรารู้สิ่งนี้แม้แต่
ก่อนที่อัลกอริทึมของ Grover จะถูกค้นพบ อัลกอริทึมของ Grover ตรงกับขอบเขตล่างที่รู้แล้วของจำนวน
ครั้งการค้นหาที่ต้องใช้ เป็นครั้งคราวมีคนเสนอวิธีที่พวกเขาเชื่อว่าเชิงอะซิมป์โทติก
เหนือกว่าอัลกอริทึมของ Grover แต่มันมีข้อผิดพลาดเสมอ หรือมีสมมติฐานเกี่ยวกับฟังก์ชัน f และ
วิธีเข้าถึงมัน หรือปัญหาอื่นที่ทำให้ข้ออ้างไม่ถูกต้อง ถ้าคุณทำงานอย่างถูกต้อง
ภายในโมเดลการค้นหา คุณเอาชนะอัลกอริทึมของ Grover สำหรับการค้นหาแบบไม่มีโครงสร้างไม่ได้ ข้อที่สอง อัลกอริทึมของ Grover
สามารถใช้ได้กว้างมาก ในแง่ที่ว่าการเร่งความเร็วแบบรากที่สองที่อัลกอริทึมของ Grover มอบให้สำหรับปัญหาการค้นหาแบบไม่มีโครงสร้างสามารถ
ได้รับในสถานการณ์ต่างๆ มากมาย ตัวอย่างเช่น บางครั้งสามารถใช้อัลกอริทึมของ Grover บน
อัลกอริทึมอื่นเพื่อให้ได้การปรับปรุงแบบกำลังสองเหนือประสิทธิภาพของอัลกอริทึมนั้น อัลกอริทึมของ Grover ยัง
ถูกใช้เป็นรูทีนย่อยภายในอัลกอริทึมควอนตัมอื่นค่อนข้างบ่อย เป็นตัวอย่างง่ายๆ
เราสามารถใช้อัลกอริทึมของ Grover เพื่อให้ได้ข้อได้เปรียบแบบกำลังสองเหนืออัลกอริทึมแบบคลาสสิกสำหรับปัญหาค่าต่ำสุดที่ผมพูดถึงใน
บทเรียนที่ห้า และสุดท้าย เทคนิคที่ใช้ในอัลกอริทึมของ Grover ที่เรามีสอง
การสะท้อนที่ถูกประกอบและทำซ้ำเพื่อหมุนเวกเตอร์สถานะควอนตัม สามารถขยายผลได้อย่าง
กว้างขวาง ตัวอย่างหนึ่งคือเทคนิคที่เรียกว่า amplitude amplification ซึ่งกระบวนการ
ที่ขยายผลจากอัลกอริทึมของ Grover สามารถใช้กับอัลกอริทึมควอนตัมอื่นเพื่อเพิ่มความน่าจะเป็นที่จะสำเร็จเร็วขึ้นแบบกำลังสองกว่า
ที่จะเป็นไปได้แบบคลาสสิก และเทคนิคนั้นมีการใช้งานกว้างขวางในอัลกอริทึมควอนตัม ดังนั้นอาจเป็นจริงที่
อัลกอริทึมของ Grover ไม่น่าจะนำไปสู่ข้อได้เปรียบควอนตัมในทางปฏิบัติในเร็วๆ นี้ ถ้าเคยมีก็ตาม แต่อัลกอริทึมของ Grover
เป็นอัลกอริทึมควอนตัมที่สำคัญอย่างแท้จริงและใช้ได้กว้างอย่างไม่ต้องสงสัย และมันเป็นตัวแทนของเทคนิคทั่วไปที่มี
การใช้งานมากมาย และนั่นก็จบบทเรียนนี้และหน่วยนี้ของซีรีส์ ซึ่งเกี่ยวกับอัลกอริทึม
ควอนตัม เราได้พูดถึงโมเดลการค้นหาและวิธีที่เราเชื่อมมันกับโมเดลการคำนวณมาตรฐานมากกว่า รวมถึง
แนวคิดพื้นฐานอื่นๆ เกี่ยวกับวิธีที่เราวัดต้นทุนการคำนวณ จากนั้นเราได้พูดถึง phase estimation
และการแยกตัวประกอบ แล้วสุดท้ายอัลกอริทึมของ Grover อย่างที่ผมบอกไปแล้ว
ยังมีอะไรอีกมากที่ต้องเรียนรู้เกี่ยวกับอัลกอริทึมควอนตัม แต่ในซีรีส์นี้เราจะไปหัวข้ออื่นในหน่วยถัดไป โดยเฉพาะเราจะ
ดูการกำหนดสูตรทั่วไปของข้อมูลควอนตัม ที่สถานะควอนตัมถูกแทนด้วยเมทริกซ์ชนิดหนึ่ง
ที่เรียกว่า density matrix อย่างที่เราจะเห็น การกำหนดสูตรนี้มีประโยชน์มาก และจริงๆ แล้ว
จำเป็นสำหรับการเข้าใจบางแง่มุมของข้อมูลควอนตัม และมันยังสวยงามมากจากมุมมอง
ทางคณิตศาสตร์ ดังนั้นผมหวังว่าคุณจะมาร่วมผมในหน่วยที่สาม และลาก่อนจนกว่าจะ
ถึงตอนนั้น